these Helen Coast Guard says at least 30
people have drowned in a suspected
migrants shipwreck it happened off the
eastern coast of Calabria in southern
Italy Italian Coast Guard said dozens of
bodies have washed up on the shore in a
seaside resort
a Europe correspondent Juan Robbins
joins us now and she won what more can
you tell us on this
well the rescue operation is still
ongoing and we know that the police
Coast Guard and fire brigade are among
agencies trying to help people who are
still in the water it's reported by
Italian news agencies that it's believed
a boat that was carrying at least 100
people some saying up to 180 people
crashed in rough seas and that bodies
have begun washing up onto the beach at
the moment at least 30 people are
believed to have died but there are
warnings that that number will rise
because as I say this rescue operation
is continuing it's thought 40 people so
far have been rescued alive but very sad
reports which are still waiting to be
confirmed officially
that children may be among those who've
died now we know that Mediterranean
Crossing is one of the most perilous in
the world there was a massive uptick in
migrants trying to come to Europe last
year and Crossing into Europe and that
area in particular is one that rescue
agencies time and again highlight how
dangerous it is at times having to
rescue hundreds of people in just a few
hours so big Focus there but we also
know that Italy has been tightening its
stance on migrants and accessing
migrants like migrants accessing Italy
and we have heard a comment from the
prime minister in the last hour saying
that she is determined to stop illegal
migration but as it stands that rescue
operation is continuing